Imagine we have two data sets.
One is a list of existing customers.
And the second is a list of prospects
that you bought from a company.
We want to reach out to the prospects
to turn them into customers.
But we don't want to contact people
who are already our customers.
The problem in this scenario is that we
need to eliminate our existing customers
from the prospects list.
However, given that there probably isn't
a nice ID code to match on between these
two files, then we need to find a way
to join the data sets on other fields.
We can use the name and address fields.
But what we find in practice is that we
don't get good matches between names and
addresses representing the same people,
because they're frequently
spelled slightly differently.
An Andrew Main at 25 State S-T for
Street,
is not going to join with Andy Main at
25 State Street spelled out in full.
So, this is where
Fuzzy Matching comes in.
Fuzzy Matching is really powerful, and
it'll enable you to join two data sets
together where a regular join may fail.
Fuzzy Matching identifies
non-identical duplicates of a dataset
by specifying parameters to match on.
The values don't have to be
exactly the same because,
Fuzzy Matching uses algorithms to score
how similar two words or phrases are.